robert cohen merci d'être en direct avec
nous peut-être évoquer tout d'abord la
mesure qui va entrer en vigueur demain
le port du masque dans les commerces les
marchés couverts les banques les
établissements recevant du public
est ce que ce n'est pas un peu trop tard
en tout cas certains le pensent le nom
je sais pas trop tendu tout ça va être
il faut le faire maintenant et il va
falloir surtout les faire de casse au
traître et durable il faut bien se
rendre compte que on n'a pas fini
d'une part dans le monde avec le public
lors la pyrrhus et donc de ce fait il
encore à porter des masques très très
régulièrement
on aurait pu le faire un peu plus tôt on
aurait pu le faire un peu plus tard mais
c'est la bonne mesure appliquée qui ne
sera pas forcément suffisante si
l'épidémie augmente d'intensité médecin
vous vous dites quoi quand vous sortez
que les astres barrière ne sont pas
assez respecté alors des plus jeunes aux
aspects quand on est dans la rue à
distance des jours quand on fait du
sport quand on se promène et qu'on n'est
pas dans un milieu fork fermé il n'y a
pas vraiment d'utilité à porter un
masque
quand on est à la verse dans un milieu
où il ya beaucoup de montées que c'est
fermé
à l'évidence de masques s'impose de
façon certaine d'où l'obligation entre
les deux on peut trouver des situations
où on se retrouve avec beaucoup de monde
très pro chez les jeunes dans la rue
hélas le masque est conseillé il faut
voir cet ensemble de situations dans le
marc c'est pas pour tout le temps il est
fait pour les milieux coule au public où
il ya du monde il est obligatoire dans
il est conseillé dans un certain nombre
autres de conditions et je pense qu'avec
ça on doit éviter d re confinement lâche
n'est pas exclu qu'on puisse être
confiné un quartier une région d un
confinement généraliser je crois que
c'est très très peu probable justement
un confinement généralisée manifestement
c'est ce que le goût
vernet en mai deux côtés on parle d'un
re confinement cible est alors déjà ça
veut dire quoi qui sera confiné où est
est ce que ça veut dire que l'épidémie
est en train de progresser en france
alors l'épidémie progresse en france où
elle progresse de façon très très
diverses et des régions ça bouge pas du
tout les des régions où ça monte un peu
on n'est pas une cuite ou du tout dans
une situation catastrophique loin de là
même je ne parle pas de la guyane ac et
la situation particulier pour vous
donner un exemple à ce moment en ce
moment dans la région de mayenne qu'il
ait des régions les plus touchées on
quand on fait des tests 6 à 8% des tests
qui étaient pays qui sont positifs
quand on était au pic épidémique on
avait plus de 50% de tests qui étaient
peu s'y déployer qu' on est loin de
cette situation là il ne faut pas on
arrivé à cette situation elle et je vous
assure que le respect des mesures
barrières le port du masque obligatoire
le le fait que quand on est même dans
des comptes tu vois pas passer des
manifestations ou des concerts avec des
gens très proches les uns des autres
effectivement là les vasques elle
nécessaire mais il est vrai que en aire
libre
leur verdict c'est à dire à l'extérieur
le risque est bien bien moins mode mais
néanmoins il existe donc si on prend ces
mesures on doit à tout prix éviter
d'aller à des mesures plus importantes
et quand on dit qu ont finalement
localisé par exemple j'ai vu qu'à
barcelone c'était certain carte il dans
d'autres régions
ça a été un petit peu plus large donc
tout ça peut être très très variable en
fonction de la circulation locale
il faut bien se compteront aussi que
aujourd'hui on a des tests pour faire le
diagnostic est très très vite
on dépiste les nouveaux cas et on
dépiste des schèmes de contagion donc
tous associés si on respecte on doit
être ce que je veux dire aussi de façon
importante c'est un terme de maladies
infectieuses l'individu est ce qu'elle
se fondre dans la collectivité
si vous avez 10 % des gens qui ne porte
pas le masque ça suffit pour permettre
au virus de continuer à se développer
donc il faut vraiment une mesure
générale c'est comme pour les fêtes
alors docteur luan vous êtes ce conte
pour les résistances aux antibiotiques
vous êtes pédiatre infectiologues alors
peu de cas ont tous les enfants on l'a
vu mais ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter le
virus peut être peut muter les enfants
sont moins touchés mais pelé touché par
la maladie et pour être précis
on craint un peu cette rentrée scolaire
de septembre parce que on sera pas en
meilleure situation que nous étions en
juin où on met le virus continuera à
circuler et il va falloir être très
rigoureux pour cette rentrée scolaire
très rigoureux pour les adultes qui
attend les relais les enfants très
rigoureux pour les parents qui amènent
leurs enfants à l'école et un certain
niveau de rigueur en intérieur de
l'école qui doit être que les
différentes classes doivent se
rencontrer le minimum si on ne se trouve
avec quelques cas dans une classe ça va
être très très facile à circonspect si
la cour de récréation où la cantine est
au vert amande en même temps les
enquêtes vont être extrêmement difficile
à mener
et ça peut vraiment gêne énormément les
jarrets ouverture nos écoles alors on
parlait tout à l'heure du rpt
confinement jeu les voir avec vous on
voit justement qu'en amérique du sud aux
caraïbes deuxième région la plus touchée
au monde alors qu'ils avait confiné a
très tôt il y a encore des cas qui
explose aujourd'hui ça veut dire quoi
chez c'est très difficile de de savoir
la situation dans chaque pays et je ne
suis pas sûr que les réactions qui sont
prises par les autorités dans différents
pays sont toujours les plus raisonnables
par rapport à la situation
donc je peux pas me permettre de juger
au cas par cas ce qui est clair c'est
que l'hémisphère sud
aujourd'hui et les zones tropicales sont
plus un danger pour la santé
l'hémisphère nord ce qui sera
probablement pas le cas quand l'automne
et l'hiver arrive donc ce convoi est
diffusée dans ces pays là eh ben ça
puisse arriver à l'automne prochain
et ça pue vraiment eu rendre là
la rentrée est extrêmement difficile
quand je vais pas me la rentrée je parle
pas que de la rentrée scolaire
je parle de la rentrée au travail je
parle là de la rentrée dans tous
essaient % par exemple si même on
appliquer le confinement si on des
confits et si on peut s'imaginer que 20
à 30 % des gens ne suivent pas des
mesures barrières le port de masques et
voit ça peut suffire largement pour
continuer ce que les nombres de cas
augmente donc il faut vraiment que ce
soit des mesures collectives
viviane appliquée je ne dis pas par tous
mais au moins par 90 95 % de la
population
si on attend dans les chiffres la caisse
qui se produit le virus continue à
diffuser parmi les gens qui ne les
appliquent pas et constitue ainsi un
réservoir important même pour les jo
robert cohen merci d'avoir été avec nous
en direct se rappelle que vous êtes
pédiatre infectiologue à l'hôpital
intercommunal de créteil dans le
val-de-marne merci